hello everybody happy Friday I got the
correct names this time oh we did it we
did it wonderful we're surfing ship it
we're done close it up welcome to
Monster Hunter Fridays let's get right
to the game Ben yo I'm ready you guys
know what it is we're gonna play monster
hunter with you guys yeah yeah this
week's a good week there's a lot of
stuff that's happened it was out finally
hey jazz hands
you know the classic Eloy just like she
does in the famous game horizon zero
darn this that's still my favorite thing
as I was making the tweet before the
show goes out and my phone auto
corrected horizon zero dawn to horizon
zero darn and I almost sent it out
that's pretty good
but yeah so we're here we're gonna be
checking out the new event quests
showing you guys the the new stuff that
came out this week and you guys can join
us somebody's asking how do you play as
a Lloyd we're gonna show you uh we all
saw a video up that actually explains it
as well it's a very good video thank you
with with a very handsome voice but yeah
so if you would like to join us the room
number is is don't don't blow down below
here and you type that in we're on ps4
jump on in do some hunts but in the
meantime I think we could probably just
go yeah so I got the skin you don't have
the bow I have everything I need but I
did not get a single a jinnah thankless
drop not a single one out a single one
um so when we do this run to show people
how it works just get me some fangs we
got it we got to get a head hit so I've
actually I've got the the leveled up bow
already because a horrible and awful and
I also have the set on so I'm gonna be
using basically all the stuff you get
get from it except for the palico stuff
because it's not as good as the gear
that I have someone's also asking we're
gonna do the wiggler quest quest we will
I got that wiggler hat and that's
probably what I'll be wearing I don't
have it do you sub to do it wants to get
the Hat I had to do it like four times
LD we won't do that then so I'll get my
hat later all right that's that's fine I
mean there are tons of quests to do this
week so that's got some personal
challenges as well yes we can fight that
uh black Diablos I Oh finally beat those
two bagel geese yeah that was a real
good fight to watch now we can go I can
I can we just spit with the big boys at
camp did you pick I just picked the
first one perfect fantastic wonderful
Stevie says hi hey what's up to you
hello good to see ya
thank you for joining us see I'm gonna
let this food animation play out because
I don't think I've actually seen a low
eat anything yet goo boobs in the chat
how's it going pretty good goob yeah
look at that meat she's very excited
about going on this hunt uh we were
talking about it earlier - she she fits
in so well she fits in really well and
it weirds me out that like I feel like
it makes more sense with the bow but for
me I'm like she's running around with
like dual daggers doing like a normal
run yeah like that's weird
how does it make sense but I'm into it
I'm down I like the idea of like an
anima and hey boy that's a hard thing to
say try to say that three times fast
anime a Loy look okay you don't have to
show me up every time I try to try to
make it thing but yeah I crash-landed in
the wrong place it started doing that
I've noticed at the higher-ranked stuff
yeah let's see so the fight that you do
the event course is called the proving
which is a callback to the first thing
you kind of do in horizon zero dawn is
she'd go on a cool hunt mission thing
and you're hunting an engine atthe high
rank engine ass yeah and you've actually
got to get some like there's a gem
you've got to get which some people
might say is pretty rare but apparently
the the cloth doesn't call you were
having trouble with you know the fang
fang the fang might be one of the rarest
things but you've got to actually fight
it a cop I got everything I got the
plate I got the gem oh he's good
I literally have everything but
but the fangs I just need to hit him he
in the head crazy gamer says they've
joined a character named Lucy will make
sure nice check it out
hope she gets a good good yeah feel free
to join this hunt by the way to like
we're oh yeah we've got two spots so I'm
engaged
oh you're already you're you're in the
in the flow of it
okay well then what's there alright I
need to pay more attention to what I'm
doing I'm going to jump in on this but
try to do my best to do some some bow
stuff it's not my main thing but uh you
got that bow so I hit that head oh you
know it I'm gonna go through the through
the body and just completely miss cuz I
ran away here you
also so the the armor is actually pretty
good yeah it's it's a high-ranked set
which is good it's high ranked said it's
a rarity five so it's not the best you
know armor in the game I'm buying
chickens but you can upgrade it though
you can upgrade it and so that's
actually pretty good
I would say it's like it's a good like
you can do some high rank stuff with it
yeah like I was actually using it right
now and it's been pretty good for me
which is cool compared to like the Ryu
set where you're like ah it's like a fun
joke set but like I don't actually want
to use this because it's like rank two
it has some cool bonuses on it but yeah
it's not same with the bow the bows
actually like a rarity like it's like
the second turbos on thirty six or seven
it might be one of the better bows I
actually have is one of the better bows
you hat you can get it's actually weight
easier to get than most of the boat so
you have to put a lot less work you
thought you got to put in some amount of
work you got to find some Elder Dragons
to get the top version of that bow but
compared to like other both you have to
make your doing a lot less to get it so
that's actually if you want yourself a
good bow I highly recommend getting the
bow definitely Bob Jones in the chat
saying uh how's it going how's it going
Bob it's going pretty good Friday yeah
so it's monster hunter today is a tough
one to hit to hit in the head especially
when you're a short dagger boy yeah I am
oh I realize why you're asking me to hit
the head a lot I'm like yeah of course
I'm gonna hit the head I've got a bow
and I'm like oh no I that's where you
get the thing I need you to break it so
I can get the Fang break that that thing
out that is probably why I didn't get it
that much is because just mangina in
particular is kind of tough to hit the
head and especially tough with the dual
blades yeah so that's probably why I
didn't actually get it just this what is
this thing telling me to do there's no
way to go here I gotta get down
gamespot so starting wonder if that's an
actual session idea I can go
double-check it but we had some people
actually join us people
so I don't know a double check here uh
your your your things you're entering
tried to hang it off and on again I got
a chance I'll double check to make sure
it's the right session no yikes please
I keep forgetting like you when you
favorite move that the bow can do and I
never use it
this is a pretty aggressive engine ass
yeah right think he's also like a like a
bigger one yeah I'm compared to the
others
when you're aiming for the head but you
miss and hit the tail in a shot that it
shouldn't hit the tail at all oh oh no I
can't run away for a second just
probably the Internet I'm willing to I'm
going to blame that alright
mmm-hmm no thank you
so there's a way you can unlock that and
actually like hit stuff behind you and
I'm trying to like some weird camera
trick I don't know how to do it just
gonna say I better like start doing some
simple mounting stuff like
or I'll just run into it and do that Bob
Jones I mean we have like a connection
in here we have like a wired connection
in the stream room as far as a dedicated
line ah I don't think so that's at a
question but I don't believe so a
corporate Internet it's weird like
before I couldn't play like any Ubisoft
games at all yeah yeah I couldn't play
siege or anything like you would try and
like load up a match just would work it
suddenly just kind of works now yeah I
remember back when for honor was a thing
and like anytime we had to do
multiplayer stuff people had to capture
it at home mm-hmm yeah that we had where
it's like oh that this specific PC line
has been set up so your PC can do it but
yeah like I can just suddenly play see
you at work now although it still is a
little finicky little kind of
occasionally crash or kick you out yeah
people says we got that login splash
screen when you connect to Wi-Fi no we
don't have that that's only for the
public Oh Wi-Fi we do have like the
actual like hey you're an employee here
here's that Wi-Fi so we don't have to do
that thankfully those shots that one
that I just pulled off that's my
favorite thing oh I like what's
happening I got sir
some wiggly hats in the in the house
this is what I'm here for
well so I'm totally switching my Lucy
rocking that wiggly hat as soon as I get
out of here yeah
I keep forgetting like how how good the
music is very good mr. dreadful is @gs
Lucy uh no definitely not she would be
off the clock at this point yeah unless
she just wanted to play some some rad
Monster Hunter yeah I mean I'm say
beliefs never just was totally Mouse
down there I'd be down I don't know she
actually plays it yeah Oh a tree fell on
me but I'm okay and maybe convinced
Tamar to play siege oh no I'm out which
is uh yeah that'd be fun I need to
network I need to play more see just
good trying to try and get back into it
I want to play a lot this weekend yeah
dad I mean um me and Jake and Matt in
that pageant I've been playing a lot
I've been trying to get in and play with
Matt and I feel bad because every time I
do it's like oh I got a that's got
pulled into a game with like some chick
doing some other stuff if you're still
putting later I'll jump in and me being
as lame as I am still haven't played
with them that's the funny thing about
discord though is you got like ten
people in like a server but it's like oh
we're all playing like five different
games yeah but I'd be down prestige this
week and I don't think I'm doing
anything so if I see you guys I'll be
like hey oh let me embarrass myself
tactical game yeah but apparently take
can't join out here it's parently
possible so actually in here it's kind
of impossible Tay there's the the blue
cord and the grey cord you have to use
the grey cord which is connected to the
switcher box is the only way we can
connect cuz yeah yeah even though we
were both on the internet with the blue
cord we're technically not hooked up to
the same box so wouldn't let us so
corporate Internet it's a lot of fun
it's it's a real good time it's not it's
not a good time
actually that makes sense because I
don't think I was able to join some
other stuff we were doing before was let
me say this game stop playing siege
would be an utter fail fast I mean I
mean you know you've some other people
read it yeah one you're not wrong but -
we were not talking about playing it as
GameSpot this we just play it as as fun
normal people yeah fun regular video
game times yeah a good fail fests if I
were to play for sure I'm Way out of
practice but I bet there's some people
in here that could probably put on a
pretty good show I think Aaron's pretty
good at that game yeah Aaron's I played
him but he he's pre into it and he's
probably pretty good
oh hello found you if we broken the head
yet I don't think so I don't think so oh
boy I just get no he's he's limping
Oh blood guy went for it trying to get a
good good shot him if he tries to like
lay down I don't think he will Oh cause
it's not it's not going to a place ray
lays down
so in size you got the wiggler how about
if not stop where you're doing get it
don't worry Ben's got I got it I got it
I got it I got to use the Eloi thing at
least once I mean use it while you're
you know we're doing the a light yeah
exactly and then after that it's wiggler
wiggler clock all the time non-stop yeah
geez get out of here Oh Taylor cut
[Music]
I need to figure out a better way to put
my my microphone or something and now I
feel like there's never a good spot to
put it I really like how how we have it
set up but man it covers on half the
screen this is really annoying
every time I keep trying to carve the
tail I kept picking up different like a
different nuts
I should probably I should probably get
the tail I wasn't gonna laugh at that
but it was all laughing it I laugh at my
dumb thing I just said I mean like it's
it's true though it's what you're oh
they're a lot over here I did the same
thing
god dammit no it's a real it's an actual
issue for me right now how did you how'd
you how'd you get around the area the
band the very tip I figured out some
funny things going on
don't ignore it you know what I'm just
gonna walk away now I got it
everything's fine we're okay gotta go
sideways but I got it I got to address
the mic properly like I got it I gotta
have it
gonna have it in my face okay I want the
room here's the head oh you got any
barrel bombs or hmm look at Ryde can you
capture him in this and yeah yeah you
can capture him ooh do you want to a
capture I'm down I could I could get
that hook hooked up
oh we already got a trap going on no
perfect somewhere I don't know where
they set it though
oh it's right here right next to him
that's how good the trap is you even see
it Aang I really want to slip this out
then yeah I'm ready
all right I didn't want to do that video
game thank you I just
cancel that
come on over this way all right bring
him over here bring him over here get
into the trap come on
Oh God something broke well all right
it's not the trap then I guess hit the
head come on buddy come on come on over
swing it over to this trap no we're
almost there
hit it make sure that's trap yeah okay
there it is oh cool go Trey you did it
just like that
perfect come on fangs give them to me
I'm a call right now you're gonna get
two fangs double fangs
I hope so that's exactly what I need
perfect that this is this is it this is
the run yeah
wiggle helmet time yes all I want I'm
just looking at it in the background of
your screen right now and I want to go
to there come on I don't see anything no
I could you just pick that one yeah I
got one
okay I got a little thing I know one
thing that's one more Fang than you had
before which is still though so you
don't want to keep doing this quest yeah
man I showed up for one thing but Lucy
carried and that's that's good times all
right
so how you do that it's actually pretty
easy you just really not that tough to
be honest it's it's it's high right like
one of the first high ranked monsters
you fight yeah yeah I do it a bunch of
times to get all the tickets but also
you need like a lot of materials as well
so you actually do need to hunt them a
fair amount yeah Cray says they got two
fangs I predicted your two fangs and not
not John Luke so close unfortunately
it's good it's just it's just one more I
got my login bonus
all right what do we got here I go over
I'm gonna change my equipment I might
pick my loadout all right I'll you know
what I'm giving up my four set maybe I
should just change my belt
yeah I'll change my belt back yeah and
we'll slot something in there I don't
know what we'll put in everything's all
Ole Miss now you know what put a kayo
jewel in there sure and we're set this
is this is gonna be me for the rest of
the rest of the game
perfect
so what do we want to do next won't do
the wiggler like we do a wiggler one
just once just to kind of show it sure I
don't know if there's like a more
effective way but you can literally just
there's one of the places you can spawn
in that has like three like spawn at the
door so you just grab them oh it's
actually just getting wigglers yeah okay
capture wigglers and that's it you'll
get your wiggle on everyday that's I'm
all about it all about the Wiggles I
think to celebrate this wiggle thing we
should get into a really cool
arm-wrestle fight because I'm sure the
physics will go all over the place
fight me fight me now do it all right
I'm ready
I'm watching
nice can't I can't can't can't be beat
too strong I'll be a let's let's do
let's do one of these one of these
wiggler things was a good a good a good
arm wrestle
hello I'm Japan hello welcome I'm glad
that you were here I'm a huge fan of you
Japan a big fan of Japan as well 10
wigglers easy it is kind of luck of the
draw on how close you are it's I can't I
can't find a better way to do it
if you crouch they don't disappear as
quickly it's true
you gotta be sneaky about it I wonder if
they'll recognize me as one of their own
now and I can just kind of hang out with
them can you actually call up multiple
people into this yeah no it's not a sign
one that's not what I'm doing
then quests wiggle me this oh that's not
that what I want I want this one I made
it I'm not gonna eat for this I don't
even know if monsters actually spawn in
times table games love this channel love
you thanks Gabe thank you for being here
Lucy gave us a meal voucher oh now I
have to eat I don't know if we need it
but dude I appreciate it we're gonna
capture those wigglers so efficiently
the only suit helps I'll just be sneaky
about it you know oh I took my wiggler
hat off for this that's not right at all
I think it'd be funny if to like try and
feed it I'm just like just I be into it
alright
and again if you guys join the session
and you you can't get into our hunt do
join other people's hunts help help them
out we're all we're all like a cool
group of people hanging out just cooing
- and hunts turning monsters into pants
this is a good time exactly even with
games I hate this channel makes them
better I mean that means a lot that
means a lot of wow that is positive yeah
yeah I love it but yeah
I I thought I'd never replace the eye
patch I know right but I replace the eye
patch so fast it didn't even it didn't
even last that long it's okay though
because red wiggler hat man what do you
think double Josette's gonna look like
I'm wondering if they're gonna do
something similar to what it's been or
if they might do do some some crazy new
stuff not sure it'll be interesting
though oh you guys all picked the the
other one so in this spawn point they're
like they're literally like right
outside of the door oh okay so you gotta
like I picked this things I remember
there being a bunch and be real right
here real sneaky about it and just kind
of like like wiggle your way up
ah they ran away I got one though I got
a wiggler that's two wigglers and then
you kind of like you can run can run
away and climb up here and I found that
if you be kind of like like you don't
sprint but you kind of take your time
kinda like come around this way and you
do like yeah this is nice seaweed that's
not seaweed I'm gonna grab this and you
head back they actually spawn in again
want to be a carrot dude don't let your
memes be dreams I believe in you
and see there they're already back yeah
yeah crouch down eh
yeah like that it's wiggler season I'm
hunting wigglers and you miss because
you're a scrub
like I'm kind of carrying this ring
carrying this wiggler you know rain if
ah I'm Jean Luc I'm the conductor of the
wiggler train like yeah that's that's
fine that's okay I'm uh got another one
I'm just gonna keep doing me alright um
I got one I contributed oh there we go
I'm gonna let red-eyes do this I trust
you much more oh yeah I just got two of
them they didn't know they didn't see it
they did all right I'll go in now that
some of this is my time to shine this is
my channel for other two dudes even
having been pulling their way at all huh
double this is that's the double damn so
that's that's the wiggler quest cool yo
catch some worms Wow
mushroom use for a game for series used
to hate the series and now I'm gonna
play the whole series what series let's
hope it's the opposite I'm gonna be a
good one
I'm gonna really rock as a mood like I
got to wiggler tickets I got one wiggler
ticket I don't need any more but it's
good to have it you know I have an extra
ticket just to remember the event but
exactly you can get a car those wigglers
good times yeah alright so livery boss
Wow the boss of delivery they called me
in high school the delivery boss so now
we got to actually get into the proper
stuff I think yeah you're gonna stick
with Luger I'm gonna stick with a LOI
okay all right I mean honoring the two
the two things the two the two main
things we've got although I like how
wiggler has definitely overtaken LA do
I'm for sure it was such a surprise
yesterday it got links around in our
slack champ you look what is this what
is this hat what is this Wiggly hat that
they're tweeting out about we had to get
ready for it
and it was good
okay so oh no I don't have enough dung
pods anymore it's a real shame it's true
that whole mission was cutting it close
I felt it the tension I say what's wrong
with my neck I'm wearing a really cool
hat that has no bones in it halo and a
wiggler what a duo it's a good IDE that
that buddy cop show may be pretty good
yeah I be in maybe a horizon zero dawn
kid put the wiggler in third on - I hope
so
time stop says the the game was the
series that was out of this country for
a while it might be ox maybe Ryu from
Street Fighter you're here I'm so happy
you could make it
why did I do this why am i why am I not
prancing I need to be prancing
let me Prince okay uh well what do we
want to do then let's see are these all
uh were these all quest from last week
no I don't think so okay so we got a
flash cleaved a bone yeah we got one
that with a Rowley boy and a note Oh
Garin in an arena but that's not even a
full high ranked set yeah and we also
got the coral waltz yeah
which gets four boys well that's the
rank seven so that's actually pretty
good one it's a pink Ratheon in there
and the proving is there again but we've
already done that I also think there's
the there's another one too right
hey where's was that that one with all
the exploding things cuz we're not oh
it's probably a quest over you can arena
that's an arena quest never mind guys
especially of course it is of course it
is of course it is
oh boy let's say I warm up to that one
then that'll be the thing yeah
definitely
do we want to do the the low rank one
yeah let's start with a low rank and
we'll go we'll just build our way out
low rank one uh it won't be that bad
I'll be pretty quick probably yeah Vince
already posted it oh shoot you're right
joint quests available quests events
take me in it's always a rush because
I'm like oh god what if what everyone
else joins in before I get it yawning a
lot today man I need it like okay it's
Friday it's the end of the week yeah
say what anyway what plans you guys have
for your weekends
you got any cool stuff come up let me
know
take yeah three the hot info
it is the arena lady perfect found it we
did it Jacquizz a treat that's a good
call at me playing yeah cos is zero
we're danganronpa maybe some siege if I
play some siege it's to kind of like
bring myself down from all the drama I
I'm having a hard time playing through
yuccas is zero because I keep playing
the darn cabaret minigame which is real
good
I don't think is a minigame at this
point I think it's actually just a game
in a game it's pretty darn good they
honestly they should just make that its
own thing put it on mobile or something
I play that heck yeah
and I'm not gonna bother with anything
energy juice I really like that I I made
my character
really gross and dumb and glowy and
wiggly time stop games how often do you
to live stream we livestream on Fridays
we're a pretty regular Friday thing
until until Monster Hunter starts to
fall off so if you guys want us to keep
staying around please keep watching
Monster Hunter or we need to find a new
thing that's before when you find a new
thing to stream which that's not a
difficult thing to know we get d-dad
alright so what are we gonna kill first
uh yo get him into the middle oh god
we've already got oh he's there's one
worried out the perfect the other one oh
that guy already that guy oh god this is
perfect that you know who's ahead of me
on that task I like all of what's
happening right now and I didn't even
realize where we were going guys
everyone's a professional Monster Hunter
now this is beautiful and I'm just
rolling around on the ground like an
idiot tails off
here we go I'm gonna try to get up here
and jump on top of that that big guy
or I'm not oh we got a turf war your
coat coexisting before though bring it
down
ah just out of reach this is just a mess
it is like I'm literally just swinging
and things are getting hit even not hit
its leg my clacker ah
Oh someone come over here you there you
go perfect there's so much stuff on the
ground yeah there's a lot of materials
it's very good oh he's dead he's dead
already
yeah I assumed we would have gotten Yoda
Karen first I thought we were cutting
the other Karen first - holy cow just
gonna keep trying to get this car yeah
oh that's what [ __ ] moss around the
world the good thing about Monster
Hunter games
stops eating me sorry I'm oh no you're
gonna no it's fine very upset it's it's
understandable even if you get the game
kind of late they're probably gonna be
people still playing it cuz Monster
Hunter games kind of don't happen very
often over here that might change now
though and if you got a PC you can
always get it on the PC oh yeah that's
right I guarantee you you'll probably
find like a like a discount or like a
cheaper what LASIK - done
yeah you can you start off with all the
PC people and it'll be a good good
adventure time so that was nice and fun
and not hard at all now feeling pretty
good about it
I could read says they wish they had a
pencil get a pen pens are cooler that's
true and I think pens probably last
longer right depends pens dip pen it
wasn't that bad right that depends on
your point of view on subscribe I messed
up I'm sorry I didn't even get the tail
I should probably grab that it says this
a new event quest yeah this is uh this
is the low rank of a low rank of M quest
they definitely have reached a point now
where I don't even know if they'll start
doing low ranks so you get to the floor
everyone's a high rank and you just
gotta keep giving them high rank stuff
they are giving us like a double
tempered hunts and stuff like that it's
gonna be uh although it's an arena one
so that'll be it's kind of a little
different yeah
nice I was gonna say I didn't show up
but I did it was it was just covered by
the microphone got to hunt the two
bomber monsters I John okay actually
just finished that one this morning do
that this morning that is not a joke
that is a very difficult stuff but you
you were the the capture captain on that
though you captured both capture well
some I was not gonna risk it I wouldn't
either
it's it's not worth it capturing is
significantly easier yeah what you miss
you miss much we've we went over the the
horizon zero dawn
Eloy stuff we went over regular stuff
the wiggler stuff but I'm gonna be
wearing that wiggler helmet the whole
time which is good we did the first new
event quest or about to jump into the
second which is the first high rank one
and we're building up towards the
special arena quest where oh goodness
we're going to have to fight those two
tempered monsters up again it's to
explody boys I'm still kind of worried
about it okay maybe I should looking at
my set stuff right now because I'm
horrible
time stop games wants to know our
opinion on Far Cry series I like it yeah
it's a go so I realized that I when I
say like how much like whenever I say a
game is big and dumb it's me describing
like my favorite games ever Far Cry is a
very big in dumb game series and I love
it just yeah because it's just like a
big sandbox where you can just do a
whole whole bunch of dumb stuff -
probably my personal favorite because
TVs - is actually real like hardcore and
yeah crazy and I like that about it how
many games do you know where your gun
can jam and one how many games do you
have malaria three also one dang
all those all's the same game it's the
city answer is the same game
Far Cry to catch it like malaria get it
goin man yeah that crazy gamer has to go
have fun and good hunting thank you yeah
thanks for stopping by is good to see ya
have a good rest of your day so I that's
the other thing though I I can't say
that I love all of the Far Cry games I'm
not like looking back at one I don't
know if you know like Far Cry vengeance
on the we can't say that like owned a
copy of [ __ ] on the Wii no not not too
into it
so I'm gonna be doing coral waltz it
looks like we are fighting basically all
of the monsters that show up in the
Kuril Islands throughout the story it
looks like he's my background that's all
I'm gonna use a voucher to and sounds
like a plan
just a sec I'm just really excited about
hunting these monsters oh yeah man if
you like Far Cry stuff
speaking of we just had an embargo for
far cry 5 Aaron and Alessandro went and
saw it and they have a bunch of gameplay
up we got impressions of the game where
Nina Mike mehar D actually like talked
to them about their experience with it
that should be going up later this
afternoon
so yeah make sure you stick around
GameSpot for that should be pretty clear
yeah I I wasn't too big in a primal a
lot of people enjoyed it it wasn't
wasn't for me too
instincts predator made me kind of upset
it's kind of more of a spinoff yeah
there's a weird one yeah yeah the
instincts games are like weird reboot
recreations yeah original game a
hardcore reimagining with really cool
superpowers and I think tutu is really
high up there
I liked three four was good five looks
like it could be a lot of fun mm-hmm I'm
excited excited for more video games
just keep giving me video games I'm also
very excited to be playing something
that isn't metal gear survive so wants
to know what's your favorite signature
weapon from the Far Cry series and you
can bring back one gun from the whole
series of our car five would it be um
geez uh it's hard to say signature
weapon because for the most part they're
just kind of like it's a gun it's it's a
gun the gun I guess like force always
cool yeah which one was the bow is it 3
or 3 3 and 4 both okay it was like the
year the bow therefore a bit like Tomb
Raider head I have are crying everyone
had everyone had a bow every was like oh
let's bring it back to like Tarak
everyone has a bow now and I'm gonna
know if there's like a signature weapon
I can specifically think of in Far Cry
yeah I guess kind of give us like an
idea of what year you're thinking of
from anything with a silencer on it yes
give me anything with a silencer on it
what game is this Dark Knight wants to
know this is master hunter world but in
Far Cry 2 that game you did not have
silent service on weapons so the the
best you got was there would be this
tranq trinket like dart gun like sniper
yeah that was the only way to like do
like stealth like long-range stuff but I
had a very very small ammo supply I said
to be very very careful with it and that
was
like a lot of fun that was like my go-to
weapon like I really liked trying to
like pick off like some you know like
certain enemies with that gun and then
trying to like sneak in like later like
I yeah I like Far Cry 2 2 is a good time
yeah found a dinosaur murdering up on
this dinosaur so why do you hate metal
gears survive I don't hate it I'm a boom
super whatever about it I am indifferent
you I don't like to that again I don't
hate it I I like I just I'm glad to be
playing something else cuz it's like
it's it's not metal gear but it's metal
gear and there's so much stuff going on
in it that it hurts my head I've been
reading a lot of oh no we got a faint
already oh that's not good we should
probably meet up with everyone let's
leave let's leave that dinosaur boy
alone for now where's another person I
think they're up fighting the Paula mu
about the weird inflatable rat oh okay
yes so I just have been playing Metal
Gear survival a lot and it's nice to
kind of be playing something else
somebody says play as a boy idiots yeah
guess what boom it's happen a lie
already doing it it's there here you're
welcome you for a little bit I just
wanted to wear my wiggly hat now your
wiggly has cooler I like my wiggly had a
lot yeah trying to find out where to go
and I don't know where to go there are
so many more of these wiggly boys and I
didn't even realize that they were all
over okay like I've seen them but I
never really like attention to very nice
to the favorite game from your childhood
all of them my joke answer is the Grinch
the Grinch the official video game based
on the movie gex - deep cover gecko when
she played a fair amount of as a kid
same I didn't get any of the references
in it
but I thought it was funny oh not get
excited the Grinch oh I didn't get any
references in the Grinch either my day
there also we're probably some
references and that I think it either
I'm sure uh actual answer probably
pokemon silver silver is the jam I can't
find anyone else who insists that silver
is the best dude was over is the best
its hands down the best pokemon game it
it is without a doubt and I'm very happy
that I've discovered this especially on
a live stream
I know Kali likes Jen to the best as
well so she might I don't know if she's
a gold or silver person I think she's a
crystal okay it's fair that's yeah it's
it is probably the best version for sure
but but Silver's the one that I over
it's the one so much time when you get
that Lou yeah heck yeah
well lugia was infinitely cooler than oh
oh hello bio long yeah I heard with what
with fingers a finger bird it was cool
looking but it's fine it's true that
only happen in the movie though I mean I
accept movies as canon for the most part
better then they get you talked in one
of the most recent ones like kind of
reassessing what I value oh you guys are
fighting the Ratheon Bob Jones let's
Pokemon crystals better silver is second
best
I'll agree with you that crystal is the
better game for sure but if you ask me
my favorites it would still be silver I
have the soft spot
yeah do that silvery make soul silver
was so good I never played it and I
really wanted to oh it was so good been
like I probably should I was like done
with Pokemon for a while and then I came
back for soul silver and it was came
back in it was good uh they added the
thing from pokemon yellow where your
Pokemon could follow you around
I remember here you could set it with
any Pokemon it's just whichever Pokemon
you've had in front of your party
ODB behind you so you can have freaking
loogie you follow you around that's all
I want
you'd sit there and tell me how how he's
having a good day and I'd be like hot
dang lugia thanks oops I think I went
the wrong way
I I feel like we're all over the place
right now who are you guys what are you
guys fighting I was fighting the Peleliu
by myself and then I was
Oh everyone's fighting the pink Ratheon
why can't I cut oh well so I just left
the pink rathian and found the path this
is a mess of a quest and I wouldn't have
it anyway
yeah okay I thought you guys cool hello
welcome to the mess the the cluster
masks hi-yah
oh I realize what it is it's because
I've been using that Zeno jiva sword for
a long time and it just has a higher
sharpness
I didn't realize somebody's running kill
monster boring game I mean you know kill
Moss was in Pokemon man like that's just
not how that works it's true they faint
exactly come back to me with your facts
straight
yeah that was a rough one
oh sorry that's our second thing right I
think so
Wow boy it's all good don't worry about
it killed anything in I was gonna try to
like work our way up to the the Ratheon
but oh god already time as far as trying
to fight build the little too late boss
Raptors yeah the flashy one yeah the
cheesy key sauce that's the way so I was
in the same boat you know we were we're
both there I remember yeah we actually
probably could have killed there by
ourselves pretty quick I do not think I
need to not be here mmm well there's fun
each other is actually good you heal
really bad yeah it is kind of like a
lugia that we're fighting a little bit
god I
I love that jeez I love it the the
monsters find each other like a lot I
still it still is really cool
okay oh geez I want to do damage but
also don't wanna die I don't wanna die
what are you doing somebody says what's
your least favorite monster so far
problem probably bagel goose yeah no
really good job of making you don't like
him I really hate him he's a jerk yeah
yeah I agree
who do we want to go for um well I think
those dudes are heading for the pink
Ratheon so I guess where we're headed on
the road again hmm oh we got that that
flash
I'm trying so hard to like just not get
God
oh boy it's a lot of fire
what's that a lever this hard to cut
through am i just like losing my mind
hmm
John dude says hi I'm new to this
channel welcome
hi welcome we play monster on earth
you're here yeah nice sclusively I mean
you know yeah we still try to convince
Randi to just change all of gamespot to
be my monster on her spot yeah I think
he's warming up to it it's he's it's a
tough sell but we'll get there I'm
wearing him down much like this pink
Ratheon wearing him down Oh God
oh yeah if if you are new please do
consider giving us a followers subscribe
to the channel so you don't miss any of
our stuff we stream every day at 11:00
or we do 11 a.m. multiple people
multiple shows multiple multiple video
games just hanging out and having a good
time with you guys so before we saw you
again you know I'd like to our news I
can eat again
come back here
honest to say I've been doing pretty oh
god this is the last thing I need don't
do this to me
don't okay you need to not be here
please leave me alone oh boy I could win
that free meal procs - that's so good
hey MooMoo how you doing oh what's up
guys
I am very shocked that I haven't gotten
poisoned yet man I don't feel very
confident that we're gonna finish this I
mean us that's fine we'll just pick
ourselves up and we'll oh boy try it
again
I'm dead it's gonna be me it's gonna be
me no bummer
all right let's you can't well back at
it again
you can't hundreds you can't one shot it
you can't why do we fall so we can play
more monster Monster Hunter it's okay
we'll get it get it again that's
probably a question for you Ben cuz I
don't know much about monsters your
rotten fail being it really I haven't
heard that but it kind of makes sense
with like what's going on I should just
I should stop reading about Metal Gear
theories and I should start reading
about Monster Hunter theories you should
probably just stop doing that in general
stop reading theories but my edge is
specifically metal Gary he's but there's
so many and they're so all over the
place I can't hit me with a good one
what's a good recent one so the best
thing right now is everyone's kind of
coming to terms with the fact that
survive is like canon and is the reason
for like the whole series existing
almost which is a wild a wild thing to
kind of deal with but I might change my
sword like the whole reason like the
idroid exists in ground zeroes and five
and all the technology that we have is
all because of what happens and survive
like right it's it's wild it's wild out
there and the fact that it has to two
endings that are both basically Canon oh
yeah so the helmet that I'm wearing is
it's the new there's a new event quest
where you can capture
wigglers and then turn them into a hat
and now it's it's like a cool hat that
has physics and Wiggles around guns and
a monster hunter game sounds fun
yeah they got they got some guns in
there ha ha bad I'm not too good at them
but they're there they're there cool
I've got here hold on maybe I can kinda
like show off some of them that I got so
you got like it's cool like bow gun that
I've been building up I've got this one
that actually kind of looks like a like
an older kind of like a flintlock kind
of gun I got a ton of bows
why do I have so many just guns in the
middle of being built it's real weird
yeah you get different ammo types with
them and you can kind of build stuff out
it's pretty pretty cool like it alright
let's try this again the worst game of
the series is a linchpin and yeah but
also acid exists but it's not a
canonical thing okay I'll start at the
southern camp okay
let's kill that tiny Raptor the tiny
raft your boy first I just want to get
him out of the way I like it
failable it's not optional that's all I
want I want event quests Oh God which
one it's this one I'm gonna use a
voucher again I believe in us I think we
can do it so on some of our planets
alien I am yeah John loose playing is
Eloy I'm right here
I'm rocking that wiggler hat let's all
screen behind you
I there we go killing it yeah I could I
could probably switch to Eloy at some
point if we need to but I just how could
I not want to be the wiggler all the
time it's just look at it
look at it look look at it I'm looking
look it's pretty good look at this hat
alright ready to go yeah
have you done the horizon zero vision
yeah we actually did it we did it once
earlier in the stream we've we've we've
finished it for the most part you seem
to get one more Fang and you can I just
a to get a Fang you can be done with it
yeah think we're getting our horizon to
next year
I hope so uh we'll definitely a horizon
to I don't know if we give him next year
I bet it not to at least 2020 yeah
that's fair takes time to make games
actly I'm broke I'm still thinking about
the tempered hunt I'm legitimately
nervous well the last time we did a
temperate hunt it wasn't that bad you
read a quest though seems like a lot
less room to maneuver yeah but there are
also really cool traps also you're gonna
get a random weapons and gear hey by the
way I tried to take the camp and it put
me all the way up here so I'm off to run
cool I'll be there in a bit he's just
fast travel I saw I could you're right I
mean that breaks my immersion though I
don't know if I like being with the fast
travel in my Monster Hunter let's keep
my experience as pure as possible
I can grab the stuff out of a box -
that's good
Adam got my Raptor boy nice I'm on my
way let's do a real cool murder and
we'll we'll skedaddle on to the next one
he was gonna say the the wiggler sounds
like something from a Batman something
like ah the wiggler my favorite Batman
villains like the calendar man the 60s
yeah Adam West one all he does is just
kind of like i'll get you batman he just
kind of sits there and kind of Wiggles
back and forth I can see it weird if
things have happened in comics I'm sure
oh definitely
apologize before and I'm using the bow
that's hot man it's all good
oh it's down there just monster stacked
on top of each other and I was like
there's no way he's up here but I still
followed dant I can't move I can't do it
let's go
oh man that other dudes trying to fight
that rapping by themselves this is not
the play guys will move we all agreed we
all agreed it was gonna be the the
flashy boy first once again no one else
joined us it's okay we'll knock this one
out and then we'll go join them this
one's already he's already hurt Hey
he goes down quick come on come on come
on I was right on the edge yeah
these nice miss completely though yikes
where did you just ride down him yep I
didn't even know you could do that he's
so tiny thing that small that's
fantastic though what up welcome to the
party Wow
oh there we go oh that's cool like a bow
that is really cool looking bow that's
that uh knowing that you know jiva
lifestyle
running away I'm really excited for Xena
GEVO chronicles two same though that's
the crossover that they should do
hey I didn't get him awesome that was
hang I didn't catch that as I was
sliding down the hill maybe I should
just become a dual blades player you
know every time I see it and there's
that little bit of me that's like man I
should just do it
dreamy girl should make the change you
got the dual pose dual fire accent right
it's true I like them a lot
I can oh god what I know what was going
on for a second there we go
come back don't run away from me I just
I just wanted to be able to jump on top
of you
there we go hey one monster down three
to go
making good time alright something there
we go
get that car VIN alright which one do we
want to go after next oh how do you
unlock a li there's a an event quest
that you can do where you just basically
hunt a high-ranked engine app and then
you craft the set mm-hmm yeah we got a
little video definitely check it out um
how you manage stamina who wants to do
that yes you know that's part of the the
thing though let's go for that a pink
graphing because I think our boys been
fighting him yeah he's gonna say she's
probably go help them out we're on our
way I think I'm going the wrong way to
get to it definitely going the wrong way
to get to it don't follow me
go climb up over here
or not climb up over here oh it dropped
down to us but yeah I'm just now cool
perfect timing totally calculated nice I
was gonna say hit that I could have just
got it like normally but this is perfect
actually I fell in that trap
yeah ooh I should have
it's it's a thing to keep track of I
guess I guess maybe it's kind of more of
a suggestion you know I like to ride it
out until the sword just literally falls
apart in my hand sometimes
Max's man there should be a GameSpot
community public discord you know that
was actually something I was thinking
about a while ago seem any kind of cool
so we do have a a office discordant yeah
but I setup that people won't really use
that much because I don't know before I
got there other cooler yeah exactly
well that guy's dude that did some you
literally so load this well-played we
could work
Wow hole as impressive two down two to
go
yeah but I was thinking about like maybe
making that like a like community thing
but then also like you know because you
can make it so it's like oh you can give
people certain like admin met yeah
privileges like these people are game
employees and they can have their own
you know chat thing but I don't know at
first I'd want actual GameSpot employees
to use it first before I would consider
turning that into something like that
because that's kind of the the benefit
of that whole situation is I should ask
I just asked Matt and because anytime we
play you know we have that one the the
pub G discord we use a lot we use that
for like everything else I should ask
them if they would be interested in
switching over to the game small one
just for man I I'll use what my more
MIDI saying like 30 different discs at
the same time they were using that one
first so it's totally fine you know just
just say that you want to play rainbow
succeeds this weekend and then we'll
both just show up in in the other one
GameSpot one will do it that way
oh yeah we're in we're in discord where
you guys what's going on and then
they'll have to the leg Jana might be up
I don't know where the Palamo might be
but lakeyanna might be the next best bet
I realize I'd been walking around in
circles not fighting a monster and I got
ya I'm already sure which to go for I
guess I'll just follow you guys whoever
finds one first I guess the leg Jana
might be up here typically is yeah make
it a sharpen on in case we get there
real soon just a tone so thank you for
the stream thank you for thank you
yeah all right I got the leg Jana in
their usual spot down for for saving the
marshmallow deed for later
[Music]
Oh God
if you'll talk about discord yeah I mean
no we definitely like we have a GameSpot
like staff discord it's just more like
do I want to convert that into a group
thing like or do we want to make a
separate one just for the community
others also I would want to make sure
there's some sort of like admin
definitely people on that just just to
you know keep an eye on it I don't want
that to grow toxic you know not because
I don't trust you guys but you know
they're always gonna be some missing bit
I was gonna be some bad people in there
there we go that's what I'm talking
about I was gonna do this
my dude what are you doing like if I
were one of these these monsters I
wouldn't think ah yes that jagged coral
on the wall I want to run my head into
that like to sound off like a good time
that sounds like a I don't know I don't
know maybe maybe like Gianna's just not
very bright
doctor
[Music]
she talked to the social team about it
yeah do that maybe the good ones to
spearhead that I mean I guess
technically I'm I'm part of the social
team yeah hey Ben hi I'm the social
scene how do you feel about a community
discord
I like the idea cool all right done ship
it I want it I want a new discord on my
desk by the end of the day and bring me
those pictures of spider-man Oh God
I also realized that I'm not using my
regular gear so I'm totally able to get
like iced by this guy and there goes do
I still don't have anything I gotta do
some no babies all right good good good
I did not think that I'm really upset
because I usually bring my well the nice
thing about this a low set is to get
that um five resistance to everything
yeah pretty good come back here you oh
you just did that from all the way up
there yeah holy cow jumped up that was
awesome this is really good
[Music]
okay that's fine won't see you later oh
[ __ ]
our other our other guys off soloing the
other monster what same dude I think so
it's the same dude that do things up I
can't believe this who is this who is
this mystery hunter mystery hunter I
haven't heard that name in years so this
is that really a lawyer just an outfit I
mean no they don't maybe pretty good if
like they just like gave with all the
character dialogue and stuff so I think
it actually changes the voice too does
it so they might have like just ran it
it's not like actual dialogue or
anything but just like weird like
grandstanding so I mean it's you're
basically playing as a boy I mean yeah
so yes it is a law in the sense that is
an actual alien model not a um about
like an outfit and hairpiece that I put
on my character anything it is the
actual like it's the model from the
actual model from horizon zero dawn
I'm just really wondering what else
they're gonna put in right like where
else are we gonna go with these
crossovers we need the Mega Man stuff
soon you do but after the Mega Man stuff
we don't really know what's coming yeah
it's gonna keep climbing up in like
there we go trying to get that amount
moving that mount life nice
you know Pokemon crossover I'd feel
really bad but I would definitely do it
do you imagine what like a Pokemon set
would look like in this game like a like
a Pikachu armor or like a it's really
grim actually as far as it's not actual
like from the skin of Pikachu say what
if instead of doing a murder on the
Pokemon what we do is we befriend them
and then they're like ah well you could
do like a Pikachu palico like yeah oh
there we go yeah that's that's the ideal
one right it just turns your palico into
a different Pokemon oh my god yeah now
you like it right yeah that's
this was near automata collaboration
actually a to bf it would be pretty good
yeah they did that with gravity rush too
and that was also pretty good it's the
only way to play gravity rush to is in
the to be outfit what else you could do
something with Soul Calibur coming up
like what other two games love giant
swords more than Monster Hunter & Soul
Calibur it's true they name they name
the whole series after one of the giant
swords it's true it's very very true but
you imagine getting like a like a
monster hunter so ledge great sword oh
that's pretty good I'd be very very down
with that come on I saw it and I rolled
right into it what is wrong with me
Debose new sub system I used to uh the
bow gear don't worry about man
no worries your your your doing work
see that the the major thing is that
you're you're having fun a good time
no one's dying which is also good less
carts are better and I'm doing this only
weariness lately that I just it's it
never stops giving so this final fantasy
15 five fantasy 15 has been all about
them collaboration it's true they
actually did a they did they did the
Ubisoft Assassin's Creed thing they're
putting gordon freeman in that game yeah
isn't noctus is gonna be checked in swap
him out for cosmic you you please and
get house cosmic you you not been in
like a tech in it just makes so much
just put him in Virtua Fighter at least
Oh have they made a new vert once last
time I made a new virtual Virtua Fighter
5 final showdown I think which is in six
at this point oh geez
but ya know if they were to make a new
Virtua Fighter
you should put Kiryu in that game it's
like what I would do was I'd actually
make was a Brad Brad burns I think is
that I think so and I just try to dress
him like Kiryu and kind of just kind of
have like a weird here you cosplay yeah
like a cure you cosplay and that's how I
do it you climb down here get that long
jump come on oh it's not gonna let me
jump off
good effort this is good we we got we
got in there though come on
I should probably put like my no berries
on to something that is much more
reachable there we go got that that jump
on that flash fly all their clothes they
got the death
[Music]
where you going you're saying
solid-state collab already a thing yeah
you did it once I'd like to see it again
just because I love metal gear so much
but chair yeah they did a really good
like with Peace Walker in Monster Hunter
trading back and forth content so where
we figured out that snake can speak cat
so that was pretty good I reckon a cat's
deep human I don't know I do they speak
human
I don't think they speak human I'm
trying to just think about all the
sounds that they make I'm just kind of
like Rico went up this way I think there
it is back to its its original place and
then it went up upstairs
hit taste saying Bend flash pods pulleys
to I didn't need a flash pot when
there's a flash fly right there I got it
yeah you saw it I left off the ledge and
I cut it open it was good also I don't
have the correct
I didn't take a shot but yeah I should
take a glider mantle just so I can
navigate around this place better yeah
Alexander says hello can you read me yes
we can how are you doing looking good
where is there we go
we should get to do a whole bunch of
like cool rope jumps yeah that's cool
you don't get to do enough of those I
think to art our other friend is still
out there soloing that that pala mu just
damn tearing it up what a baller oh
we've got we got everything set up I'm
just and he just killed that pala Moo
hey it's dead
hey guess we're not gonna get the carve
on that one lay it out do it do it V
Phoenix this is all you oh I guess we
also didn't get the carve on the other
one to shoot that's fine oh man actually
I can't want to like that pink Ralphie
no I think about it do it up do it up
this is all you just do two laid out lay
it out for me you're good man you kiddo
kid get him get him get him get him get
him
yeah just do it
I was excited cuz I was kind of hoping
that it'd like explode and it would just
like cause us to die right away
Oh like what happened with the one elder
dragon yeah that was a little
anticlimactic yeah oh no oh I can't die
I don't want to be the one who dies I
don't want to be the one not today
second live video you've watched today
dude you're on a roll but I'm glad that
you chose us for your second video
George I'm glad you're here
man we did it just like that easy as
it's easy as cake smoother than a molten
core run that actually didn't go as bad
as I thought it would oh I got a leg he
on a plate finally be able to put that
set together could have totally skipped
over before Oh liked the video thank you
appreciate it
I was looking at the Karen a female beta
set good yeah yeah just it's just rave
gear like it's it's a heck of a thing so
I keep creeping towards the camera
this is the best get is this game is
it's so so dumb and floppy
yeah well we'll get some some boner
stuff off of the other other stuff we
killed so that's that's that's all good
not too worried about it
hello Zhen Jin I think I said your name
right okay we got time to try out that
that final thing oh you want to just go
in you want to do the yeah yeah I was
kind of hoping that with like you know
would take too long and then we put oh
no we can't do the hard one we got time
to try it once you got time to give it a
shot all right I'm in I can't promise
we'll keep doing it
hi old man Roman you seem lost
I'm here for you man yeah
so I think this one you fight we're
fighting a tempered bagel goose and a
temporary I don't remember the name of
the dinosaur that shoots all the
explosive stuff out I should actually
check this out really quick give me my
hi bounties please here we go more
armored spheres so I can I'm gonna
actually go dump some stuff into my into
my helmet cuz I actually have an
upgraded to upgraded it at all and that
would probably be a smart thing to do
what armor is that I'm wearing
mostly oh it actually is at this point
it's all Oda Garen and then I've got the
the wiggler helmet on top of it which
this was for PC it's on its way Orien
well we'll all be able to do some sweet
PC hunts coming up real soon
I'm by real soon I mean hopefully not
too far off let's see okay you know what
just yeah dump all that in there just
bring it up to level 5 7 8 this is this
is what we need I need to just get it
all the way up there
there we go max aw that's pretty good
actually
yeah 668 it's not bad I like that is
that I think it's actually using too
much I'll take it to the one before max
will leave it there so I've got a little
bit more defense I'm on my way up to the
area we'll start that hunt up hopefully
we'll be able to do it alright that's
old site oh thanks for for hunting it
was it was really cool have a good good
day miss you I don't I don't know how to
pronounce their name but they came they
soloed some monsters and left perfect
god bless you I just gotta quickly get
my tail rider stuff right now and then
I'll get ready to post it up when I back
out to talk to the correct person and
then we can we can all join up and make
this make the dream happen
all right so challenge questoin expert
115 or higher we can faint 9 times damn
it's like she pretty leaning well good
it has a switch axe okay this is good
it's getting a rank we have to finish
this in five minutes 30 seconds whoa so
shooting for ass see rank I'm probably
can you switch axe you're probably do
have dual blades so that'll be good yeah
I was really worried action that was the
thing I was more worried about than the
fact that it's tempered monsters is the
fact that I might not be able to use any
weapons that I knew how to use is there
an upcoming history of Monster Hunter
guys Chris Dixon wants to know on
YouTube
9:8 time soon but not taking it off the
table entirely now not taking off the
table entirely but not anytime soon it's
it's a heck of a thing to tackle because
it's there's a lot going on and I I
personally don't have the experience
with a any Monster Hunter air past this
one so I would need to either do a lot
of research but I should it's fine I've
done that before or maybe get some
outside help from some Monster Hunter
experts so we should uh we should do
that thing where we just play the first
Monster Hunter on Monster Hunter Fridays
and just start start with going hey yeah
oh prong one all right I'm going to oh
wait this is only for us so it's
two-person it's a two-person quest I
know anymore
alright I'm gonna post it up
should be there in a second chat is it a
challenge yeah alright I mean this is
this is just us so like there's we can't
blame anyway if anything goes wrong I
don't need to eat cuz it's an arena
right thank you thank you thank you
Steve do you like what is a 500 500
zhenia something something like that I
so love the history yeah kiza thank you
it's really well done miquel did a good
job on that one it's one of my favorites
alright here we go
um ideally oh it's a whole bunch of
vallis ox stuff this is like this is a
good soo
I like this these are some good
varieties of gear I'm using the quirian
uh dual blades oh dang I think I think
those are the Karin weapons all right
what are we what are we who are we going
for first should we go for the the big
guy or should we you can't we're in an
arena so we can't like make one of them
run away oh you can split the the thing
up so we actually can split one off from
the other so that that's the thing we
could do will they fight each other make
sure you use your your max potion and
your your meats right now yeah soon be
here yeah I'll see my well done stay up
oh we got some sleep knives vitality
Mansell in a health boost err okay a lot
of bombs evasion mantle so I think we
should split them off when like bagel
groups is over there right now we can
just split it off and we can try to like
hit this guy bit okay yeah let's do it
I'm real nervous I'm gonna try to hit
that lever but I think I think they're
gonna see me before I do it don't look
at me don't look at me don't look at me
don't look at me telling me tell look at
me
all right so nice separated off at least
okay so this guy's probably gonna use
some of the barrel bombs on right yeah
I'm down explosions are always good
come on over this way pal yeah I don't
know bounce bombs do they you put them
down when they fly up into the air
okay you just yeah thank you
Oh God
oh no oh jeez second there we go get out
of here with that no no no no no no no
no no no please don't please vengeance
Blitzer is saying that in the session
they posted some horizon zero dawn
events and that there are some spots
open so yeah anyone who's like playing
also like you can join the session and
just play with other people which is
really fun jump on up in there and get
yourself some really cool Eloy gear
that that said sidestep this boy needs
to get closer to me so I can do a thing
I can try to help he heard me you heard
me say it oh yes I'll head over there
right away
man these caring weapons look ridiculous
there we go that's what I was looking
for
can you open back in you can you you
gotta wait for the bomb to go off
smoothly just keep up no no he knows
he's aware oh boy all going according to
plan
maybe I can distract him I'm not doing a
good job of that all right I'm on top of
the exploding t-rex so I should be only
knocking down here in a second maybe or
he'll just get knocked down cool well
they are attacking each other
tails go off that's good dang that tails
huge Gary ah they're both flashed
perfect oh this a lot of teardrops
man this quest makes me so uncomfortable
yeah who's nervous okay I think they're
do you act alone I'm going for the tail
cars
wish me luck I think I think you just
get like potions and stuff back oh no I
did you're right but uh you know that's
more of that's more healing yeah that's
fine Oh God
don't be dazed literally in between both
of them don't there but they both
decided to attack me perfect
I try to jump off here again
and totally whiff
hey please stop knocking me gonna do
that
oh that was very good hey fences ready
use so we try to separate them out again
see who comes to the other side I guess
come on
Oh hit that thing ya know well this wait
yeah I was like oh god did you like get
locked on the other side somehow no no
no I don't know if how it looked under
your screen but for a second he popped
in on the other side oh and but then he
popped in on this side Oh see he like
rocket launched into this area yeah I
was I was worried I hit it too early and
then we were gonna be sitting here just
waiting which oh yeah we builded I need
to not die I need to not die I need to
not die please don't die okay don't
worry I'm gonna do a thing do that thing
I have a vitality mantle what am i doing
I'll put a health booster back down at
the bottle go go okay I need to know
whetstone really quick
this hill is good this hill is very good
come back where are you going
I think we both jumped off the hill and
we both miss yep
are you kidding
got him okay this is this is real good
now we just got a fight
our boy I'm gonna definitely get these
carbs on him because it's more yeah get
some more potions I heard he's just
sitting there on the fence like
mean-mugging us he knows uh-uh
I don't like this so oh dear no you can
do that like you can kind of climb and
then do like a leap off the oh nice good
to know all right now we're now we're in
it this is the oh boy oh boy it's so
nervous to hit him at all when he's read
like that how many traps I don't think I
do
oh my god what's a far caster it's
basically what you escape
oh wow on do that so you can like if
you're about make a bomb barrel way
never make a bomb barrel I'm gonna try
to lead him back to you come on I didn't
really help this way oh I do have a trap
he's coming he's coming he's coming he's
coming he's coming
he hit it didn't really stop him but
that's fine yes that's okay I got the
trap down though oh cool oh God
oh shoot don't die John we fell right
into it we're good
oh good that's got a roll
Paul that was really almost bad pull
dang it
alright I got some head hits I'm totally
messed with that see I can put him
asleep she got I got sleep knives Teddy
good sitting I was on deck army
completely with some of them yeah there
we go he's asleep you have any more
things dollar oh sorry no I actually
didn't
I've mega bounce bombs though oh that
really oh that was bad oh boy Gavin e
bomb barrels are now No so give me a
bunch of just a bunch of the knives to
kind of throw at him start getting into
my regular potion together yeah let's
see here
okay can seconds I can do this that
actually worked really well they're
they're pretty good
the timing of them is kind of a little
tricky though it's gonna shoot all my
knives at him go for it because there's
no reason not to be using the poison
ones and eat him up
oh this is perfect time for me to well I
was gonna be a perfect time for me to
flash him but he's poisoned and with the
mount - dang it
you don't want to like I don't want to
jinx it or anything but I think we might
be able to do this I think I think we
might I think we might have this
yeah
yeah hit him in the head tails gone
tails gone Oh beautiful
come on down you've won a brand-new car
this is the spoiler it's not really a
car though
come on
look
unequip my my flash pod and got him nice
ice ice too soon too soon
[Music]
I feel bad cuz like I haven't looked at
the chat the entire time we've been
doing the same I promise I promise still
love you guys it's just this is this is
very frightening just ninja run through
those explosions do you think so
dang turn around turn around turn around
oh no I botched it
up the tree off the tree totally missed
that's fine all right did that
whoa
he's real real angry right now he's not
happy less no that was the worst I hate
when that happens you get knocked down I
like doing a really cool thing so even
if I'm in the air if he does the roar it
like stops your animation with that it's
really dumb actually I don't think it
should do that there's actually I think
a step that's for not having that happen
but oh he'll fly at me I don't have any
more flash pods
come on come on there we go
this is gonna be a really good finishing
screen for me because I like sword
uppercut I'm really excited to see how
it turned out
holy cow we did that uh I don't need to
cut him open but I'm gonna cut him open
anyway I'm open huh I need everyone in
the chat yeah how's it going oh man not
too much oh I thought it was gonna it's
not cool I can kind of see it on my
screen I've got to mine
all right go okay I kinda sorta see it
kind of cutting up in there
dang registering world rankings best
time has been how do you think we stack
up against everyone else what was our
time oh yeah was that was that
everything dad was everything dang we
did it we did it all we did all the
things fantastic do we do we want to try
to get thrown back on like Diablos for
15 minutes are doing no unfortunately I
think we're gonna have to call here
that's totally cool fine thank you guys
for tuning in to this week's Monster
Hunter fridays been pretty good one it's
a really good one this fight was a heck
of a time yeah not as bad as I thought
that in my head I was just like oh this
is gonna be bad yeah that was actually
pretty fun so yeah so we're gonna be
doing it next week once again just make
sure to tune in for that
make sure to step back or come back
every weekday cuz we always do stream at
11:00 and see you guys next time
[Music]